let's start with what is most important
this is the most devastating day in the
history of Virginia Beach the people
involved are our friends co-workers
neighbors colleagues
you know you know at this point I would
like to turn things over to chief severa
to give you the information that we have
so far
I'm going to UM give the information
that we have at this time we as we
receive additional information we will
release it when it's appropriate so what
I know at this time is the information
we're going to release right now I can
tell you we have multiple casualties and
multiple fatalities we have eleven
deceased victims they are at the scene
we had six more victims who were
transported to area hospitals I do not
have the condition of those victims at
this particular time I can tell you that
one of the individuals shot by the
suspect is at Virginia Beach police
officer and he was saved by his vest
we've established a Family Assistance
Center princess and middle school that's
at Nemo Parkway in Holland Road for the
employees who worked in building two so
that they can meet up with their friends
and their families we're also in the
process of identifying all of our
victims so that we can make personal
notification to family members we do
know that shortly after 4:00 p.m. this
afternoon the suspect entered building
two he's a longtime employee of public
utilities I will not release his name at
this time and he immediately began to
indiscriminately fire upon all the
victims officers entered wants to call
one out the officers were at
headquarters they responded to building
two they secured as much of the victims
as they could and then they engage with
the suspect suspect did shoot a police
officer officers returned fire suspect
is deceased
while the scene is secure we have a
long-term investigative process that's
on being undertaken right now there's a
lot of work to be done it's still an
active scene we are being assisted due
to the size and scope and intensity of
this scene we're being assisted by the
FBI forensic unit DHS forensic unit and
the Virginia State Police forensic unit
medical examiner also is on route which
is a protocol for the medical examiner's
office right now we have a lot of
questions with the wise they will come
later right now we have more questions
really than we have answers or a little
more than two hours into this event and
we use the word event that's a cop term
this devastating incident that happened
that none of us want to be here talking
about this devastating incident which is
going to change the lives of a number of
families from our city so my goal will
be to update you and confirm additional
information as soon as we can
our next briefing should be at 2130
hours we have been told that the
governor is in route to this scene we've
been notified by our state senators and
by various and sundry other elected
officials offering their condolences to
our city and to our
family of those of us who work in
Virginia Beach